y los líderes señalados mantienen que no
han actuado fuera de la ley
usar paraísos fiscales lo sabemos no es
en sí mismo un delito pero porque eleva
las alarmas ese movimiento de bienes
sí buenas tardes
si lo que
tenemos que decir primero es que per se
no es un delito como bien dices de la
creación de estructuras offshore pero sí
es importante resaltar de que este
ecosistema no aunque se mueve en
paraísos fiscales esos lugares
exigen una muy baja tributación y que
además tiene una legislación que
favorece el ocultamiento de los
verdaderos accionistas de las compañías
no
genera también una economía ilícita así
como tiene usos legales también los
criminales los funcionarios corruptos
toda la gente que comete crímenes
suelen recurrir a estas estructuras
offshore en paraísos fiscales
precisamente para que no se encuentren
[Música]
su fortuna las autoridades y lo que debe
preocuparnos es que los políticos que
están aquí
mencionados son precisamente quienes
están llamados a hacer los cambios no
en las propias legislaciones anti
alusivas
entonces esa es la principal
preocupación cómo es que los líderes los
mismos líderes que están llamados a
hacer los cambios tienen este
estas estructuras en estos paraísos mire
y que tanto impacta esta investigación a
la región latinoamericana con la
claridad de que los presidentes de
ecuador de dominicana y de chile además
de dos ex presidentes colombianos al
menos hacen parte de esta lista
así es pero enteramente además que si
nos referimos a la región
latinoamericana no solamente son
políticos sino también hay personas que
estamos investigando
que tiene que ver con otros tipos de
crímenes también funcionarios de menor
rango no está recién empezado sin ha
habido un día de publicación o hoy día
van a seguir las publicaciones y así se
espera que continuemos no durante la
semana también bueno y algunas figuras
públicas mencionadas en el informe han
negado su vinculación con los dichosos
paraísos fiscales pese a la evidencia
que la investigación presenta a quien
les creemos a quien le creemos y por qué
sí bueno está
alguien puede negarlo no pero
precisamente porque quizás
uno no nos espera que toda esta
información salga a la luz
ahora recordemos que esta es una
filtración masiva que ha permitido una
investigación bastante mayor a lo que ya
se conoció antes que eran los panamá
papers no donde solamente
hubo la filtración de un bufete panameño
que era mozart fonseca esta vez tenemos
14 bufetes sido objeto de esta
filtración entonces la investigación es
muchísimo más grande y se pueden hacer
mejores cabos